[Applause]
costume designers makeup artists hair
stylists you can't imagine what we owe
these people no no you absolutely cannot
every one of us except for George
Clooney who does in fact roll out of bed
camera-ready is for ever shaped by these
brave men and women who paint cut bend
twist shave and in some cases even wax
us into the characters that you see on
screen wax yeah no welcome to the club
Jan that's so fun is it no no it's not
no so it's alright don't worry about it
so tonight we honor our incredible
unsung heroes the behind the scenes
artists who've crafted your favorite
characters of the year here are the
nominees for achievement in costume
design Anna Karenina costume design by
Jacqueline Duran
[Applause]
Lim is a Rob costume design by Paco
Delgado Lincoln costume design by
Johanna Johnston Mirror Mirror costume
design by a co-co-co Snow White and the
Huntsman costume design by Colleen
Atwood the Oscar goes to Jacqueline
Turan
[Applause]
this is the first Academy Award and
thirty nomination productions around
for atonement and Pride and Prejudice
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you to the Academy this is
absolutely overwhelming and I'd like to
accept it on behalf of a great team that
worked with me on Anna Karenina a
wonderful director Joe Wright fantastic
producers at working title and my
children fur bearing with me they're
completely oblivious to this they're
fast asleep in England thank you very
much
[Applause]